for my Ally is the force and appall for
colleges life bleeds it makes it grow
its energy surrounds us and binds us
illness beam so we not this crude matter
you must feel the force around you you
betrayed you me it's me everywhere yes
even
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be an explainer for the New Jedi
Order that's rising up in the been do if
you've never heard that term been do or
die been do is the original name that
George Lucas had for the Jedi in his
rough draft for the first Star Wars
movie now a lot of things change but the
new films as well as Star Wars rebels
are going back to those ideas so if you
didn't know I'm doing Star Wars Fridays
for the rest of time there is new Star
Wars giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's for two imax
gift certificates so we talked a lot
about the last Jedi as in the Jedi Order
is done something new is coming in both
kylo Ren in Rey Luke is seeking the
truth of things at the original Jedi
Temple and if you've heard or you've
read the original rough draft of Star
Wars by George Lucas you hear about
something called the die Ben do the
original name of the Jedi they have a
character on Star Wars rebels this
season called the Ben do who is based on
that idea the truer interpretation of
the force then both the Jedi Order the
Sith or any other dark side Force X used
you may have heard about the rebels
Easter eggs that appear during Star Wars
rogue one like the ghost ship or general
Hera they try to be very consistent with
the mythology through the animated
series the books that they're writing
right now the expanded material in the
saga films most of the time that's for
continuities sake but in this case it's
in the nature of the force in the
direction that the new trilogy is going
with it so you have this idea that
they're trying to move past these old
traditions the tradition of the Jedi
Order the tradition of the Sith the
first time we meet the Bendu character
on rebels he helps Kanan see the truth
of things like he sees what he wants to
see the Bendu tries to get him to see
the real truth so here's that clip to
tee that up you had my call good
your imbalance woke me from a deep
slumber imbalance your presence is like
a violent storm in this quiet world
you're a force wielder but you're not a
Jedi well done
Jed I am Sith wheel the ashlar and
Berggren the light and the dark I'm the
one in the middle why aren't they
attacking it is not in their nature well
it has been in my experience because you
do not see them you mean see them for
what they are no no sir it's me
fear grief anger that's how they see me
that's how I see myself your sight
returns
so imagine ray getting a version of
those types of lessons from Luke
Skywalker Luke Skywalker is sort of the
Kanan of the Saga films presumably he's
learned those things so he's passing
those on to Rey so she can become the
first of this new order you can call
them Jedi you could call them die Ben do
you could call them Ben do they might
attach a name to them in the new trilogy
but my bed is is it'll be very close to
the idea of Ben do but all signs point
that they're moving back to this base
Ben do where the original idea of the
Jedi started from so in a practical way
all the characters are going back to the
original ideas about the Jedi and in a
meta way the writers the producers the
people that make Star Wars are going
back to the original ideas so if you
haven't been watching rebels you don't
absolutely have to but they do cover a
lot of very cool ideas based on what the
Ben do teaches them in the context of
the animated series the Ben do helps
Ezra and Kanan balance themselves in the
force so you have to imagine the light
side the dark side on the other balance
being in the middle so in pursuit of
that they do a lot of really cool stuff
like trying to combine Jedi and Sith
holocrons like he warns them that doing
so will give them this ultimate
knowledge but it comes at a price so you
have to think of it in the way that you
think of Anakin's force
so he's very powerful he has forced
visions but the path those visions lead
him on becomes this very
self-destructive self-fulfilling
prophecy until his ultimate Redemption
at the end of Episode six so this is
what Snoke and Luke Skywalker are trying
to do find balance in the force
Snoke has a slightly more nefarious
approach to it he's trying to turn kylo
Ren into this ultimate balanced Bendu
Jedi but Luke is trying to do the same
thing with Rey and you can imagine that
you know just based on the way the
narrative moves that they'll slowly
reach this balance enlightenment around
the same time before whatever epic
battle they end up having so as much as
this is a story of the last Jedi it's
also the story of the first of the new
Jedi we can call them the new Jedi as
shorthand but really Ben do would
probably be more appropriate or even die
Ben do if you really want to go back to
the origins so if you don't know the
story of the original rough draft it's
actually pretty fascinating most of you
probably know that the character we know
is Luke Skywalker used to be called
Anakin Starkiller his father was named
Caine Starkiller who asked general Luke
Skywalker this is the rough draft
remember so I know it sounds a little
confusing to train his son so in the
original rough draft Luke Skywalker was
general Kenobi
so that changed to Luke Skywalker being
the protagonist his father was still a
cyborg but he became Darth Vader so they
kept that idea in the general Luke
Skywalker from the rough draft became
the obi-wan Kenobi character but the
opening conflict wasn't so much the
Death Star plans as it was this
transition of power between the Knights
of the Sith in the Jedi Bendu order in
the Galactic Republic
Lucas referred to that opening conflict
is the great Jedi rebellion so there
wasn't quite as much galactic politics
going on it was more of a Jedi centric
story but there's this really important
quote from that rough draft that gives
you an idea for what's going on in the
new trilogy Kaine Starkiller is talking
to general Skywalker saying take my son
he's talking about Anakin Starkiller the
Jedi Bendu must survive we must pass it
on only a Jedi can stop the Empire were
very old a new generation of Jedi must
be
started take him teach him the way of
the Jedi been do if that idea sounds
familiar it's because during the force
awakens when we meet Rey people like
Luke Skywalker the Jedi they're just a
myth she doesn't know what it is to be
force sensitive she's only heard stories
about what happened this is about thirty
years after the original trilogy ends so
it's been a long time in the empire in
the first order after them basically ran
a smear campaign against Luke Skywalker
blaming all of the problems on him
everything was going great there was
economic prosperity till Luke Skywalker
came along and ruined it all for us so
imagine the worst kind of galactic
yellow journalism just smearing him all
over the tabloids so Luke goes to find
the true origins of the Jedi while this
is going on so nobody believes in the
Jedi anymore
we need a new order to rise up we don't
know exactly how Snoke is going to be
training kylo Ren but you have to
imagine that there's going to be some
parity between their lessons they'll be
learning some of the same things from
slightly different perspectives but
listen to Obi one's original speech to
Luke Skywalker about what the force is
the force the force is what gives a Jedi
his path it's an energy field created by
all living things it surrounds us and
penetrates us it binds the Galaxy
together the important thing to remember
here is that obi-wan has already learned
to create force ghosts he's already
learned that lesson so he has a more
complete picture of what the forces he's
not just talking about the light side of
the force the force flows through a Jedi
through every living thing so that's
going to be really important for Ray's
training deepening her connection with
all living things with the planet with
the animals with the rocks the trees the
way that Yoda talks to Luke about how it
just flows through everything so I don't
want to talk too much about rumors from
behind the scenes but there have been
some stories from this set that some of
her training montage moments will play
out in funny ways based on that idea her
trying to attune herself with the nature
of that island there and that planet but
let me know in the comments what do you
think about the idea of kylo Ren in Rey
becoming
Bendu in the new trilogy as opposed to
just being Jedi or Dark Jedi or Sith or
just a more powerful version of the
Knights of Ren the way they explain the
Knights of Ren and I'll do a separate
video about this is that they're really
just the new thing to replace the Sith
so there's still very much darkside
force users but if you have any requests
for other Star Wars bonus videos episode
8 or any of the other films just leave
them in the comments below remember that
Fridays are now Star Wars video days
till the end of time so there's all
kinds of stuff that we have to talk
about what's gonna happen next is is
there's a video that I want to do about
Chewbacca kylo Ren and the idea of his
life debt and how he's going to resolve
that so that'll probably be my next Star
Wars video but congratulations to the
new giveaway winner Scott Sanson you
went to IMAX gift certificates please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll announce the
winner when I post that next Star Wars
video so that'll either be on Monday or
Tuesday or you wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about
snoke's backstory in episode 8 and you
can click here to learn about the
Guardians that are gonna be appearing
during infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you in the next video mini-me
[Music]